Good morning. Hank. It's Tuesday
It's time for an unboxing video
So as previously noted, if you open up any of these boxes you'll find... you know, yet another box
But it is not boxes all the way down because, if you open up this box what you'll find is
paper lots of paper like that particular box contains two thousand sheets
And I am signing those sheets of paper one at a time over and over again
I've been doing it off and on for about six months actually
It's been a little bit hard to keep this all a secret
But when I announced last week that I finally have a new book coming out, Turtles All the Way Down, coming out October 10th...
Lots of people were like, 'are you going to sign all the pre-orders? Will all the pre-orders be signed?'
No, I want to be very clear about that. In fact, there is a website
Will all pre-orders of Turtles All the Way Down be signed dot com
No.
So the only way to sign all the pre-orders for a book is to sign the entire first printing. For The Fault in our Stars
That was a hundred fifty thousand copies. Some of you might remember this, which Sarah made for me in 2011 to help me,
you know, chart my path to
150,000 signatures because I did sign almost all of the pre-orders for that book.
But Turtles All the Way Down is going to have a first printing of like
1.5 million copies, and it's just not possible to sign that many books. I looked into it.
Maybe somebody could do it, but not me. However,
I am going to sign 200,000 copies of the book. H opefully slightly more
but at least 200,000.
Again, just to emphasize this does not mean that all
pre-orders of Turtles All the Way Down will be signed because they won't. For one thing
This is only going to work in the US and Canada
I'm really sorry if you live outside the US and Canada, but on the upside by not being American you probably get universal health care.
So, maybe that's even worth more than an autograph?
Okay, so in the book world there are these things called
ISBN numbers. Every book has one. They used to be ten digit numbers.  Now there are 13 digits.
And for many years a large percentage of my job was typing ISBN numbers into a database, so as it happens I know a lot about ISBN numbers.
For instance, each publisher has its own particular ISBN Prefix.
0-06 is Harper- Collins. 0- 316 is Little Brown. 1-224 is The University of Chicago Press. I could go on but you'd get bored.
In fact, my first thought when I found out looking for Alaska was going to be published by Dutton was I'm going
to be a zero dash five two five dash.
Incidentally, I'm very proud all these years later to still be published by dutton and still be a 0-525- but I
Am on a tangent. Right, so Turtles All the Way Down has two
ISBN numbers. One of those ISBN numbers is for signed books.
Everyone's going to have some signed copies: your local bookstore will have some; target will have some;
Amazon will have some;
ETC, and you will have the highest chance, although still not a guarantee, of getting a signed book if you order that ISBN number.
There are many links in the dooblydoo to buy the book with that ISBN number from all over the place.
But let me just quickly say that if I were you, I would order the book from my local bookstore.
So yeah, that is the ISBN for the signed edition.
It doesn't cost any more than the regular edition it's just more likely to have a signature. Also, Sarah took this from
2011 and made me this for 2017
It's a thermometer resting on the back of a turtle that is itself resting on the back of another turtle
Presumably ad infinitum. As you can see here since January, working when I had extra time,
I have reached 80,000 books and then I have, like, about two months to just
Zhoorbaderk! (nonsensical noise)
Get there.
By the way, if you're wondering what 80,000 sheets of paper looks like, this is 38 fidget spinner for scale.
And there's another 42,000.
Most of the pages are just signed,
but about three percent have a DFTBA on them. Then there's also bunch of them that have yetis drawn by Sarah.
There's also a few that Alice has circled in hot pink.
And there are several hundred that Henry has drawn pokeballs on. It's kind of a family affair, this signing thing.
So Hank, that's the news. I have a new book coming out. It's called Turtles All the Way Down.
I am so excited and also so relieved I'm going to sign
200,000 copies, or hopefully slightly more. And, if you live in the US or Canada, you can pre-order a signed copy at your local bookstore
or via the links in the doobly-doo. Hank, I got to get to signing I'll see you on Friday.
PS. One more thing. I need your help deciding which sharpie colors to use there is a survey in the doobly-doo. Thank you. Bye